morgen erfahren wir wie teuer die
gasanlage wird die preise gehen durch
die decke die ampel streitet über
entlastungen es wird ein politisch
heißer herbst also genug gründe für ein
gespräch mit dem fdp vorsitzenden
christian lindner und damit herzlich
willkommen zum zdf sommerinterview
diesmal aus berlin
[Musik]
hallo ich grüße sie und hat mich mit
vielen dank danke für die treffen uns in
berlin-mitte blickweite kanzleramt
bundestag hauptbahnhof also auch in
gewisser weise im spannungsfeld ihrer
ihre arbeit danken wir beim hauptbahnhof
40 millionen mal ist es nur ein euro
ticket verkauft worden also eigentlich
durchaus ein erfolg sie nennen das
gratis mentalität oder tun ist ein
gratis mentalität so richtig beliebt
machen wollten sich um ein nicht oder
wir müssen die richtigen lehren ziehen
aus dem neuen euro t können wir müssen
das richtige tun ich glaube wir können
etwas lernen der komplizierte nahverkehr
die nicht durchsichtigen tarifstrukturen
bundesweit und auch die mangelnde
digitalisierung können wir überwinden
das ist die lehre des neuen euro tickets
aber es wäre eine illusion zu glauben
wir könnten den nahverkehr kostenfrei
machen wir brauchen das geld um ihn die
schiene zu investieren für die bildung
für entlastungspaket einen neuen euro
tickets ich sehe nicht die gelder dafür
aber das wort gratismentalität guido
westerwelle hat man von spätrömischer
dekadenz gesprochen ist dass die lindner
lust an der provokation so ein wort oder
ist es die mobilisierung ihrer kern
anhängerschaft weder noch ich gehöre zu
denen die klar ansprechen was ist und
ein kostenfreier nahezu kostenfrei
öffentlicher personennahverkehr das ist
nichts was wir auf dauer leisten können
irgendjemand muss das ja bezahlen also
der steuerzahler
und wir müssen mit knappen ressourcen
geld kapazitäten der bahn müssen wir
sorgfältig umgehen und ich muss leider
immer daran erinnern es kann nur das
verteilt werden was zuvor erwirtschaftet
wurde klar ansprechen was ist ist genau
das stichwort für unser interview bitte
schön wie vor nicht
[Musik]
auf die bürger kommen harte zeiten zu
wir sehen dass die inflation durch die
decke geht morgen erfahren wir die höhe
der gasanlage es gibt meldungen aus der
politik dass die bis zu 1400 euro
betrifft für eine vierköpfige familie
und offensichtlich nach eu recht kommt
dann möglicherweise auch noch
mehrwertsteuer darauf können sie das
noch verhindern wir tun das was in
unserer macht steht sowie die gasanlage
konzipiert ist wird sie nach
europäischen recht der mehrwertsteuer
unterworfen das war bei der früheren
sogenannten eeg umlage auf der
stromrechnung hier auch so ich habe nach
brüssel geschrieben und setze mich dafür
ein dass abzuwenden an jedem 2 in jedem
fall müssen wir eine möglichkeit finden
dass dieser sag mal solidarischer akt
das ist es ja das wäre nicht auch noch
mit einer steuer belegt wird und der
staat davon profitiert es gibt den
vorschlag wenn es denn zu dieser
mehrwertsteuer kommt aus dem saarland
von der ministerpräsidentin dass man
dann die mehrwertsteuer um verteilte an
ärmere haushalte hätten sie damit
einverstanden
über solche dinge kann und muss man dann
sprechen ich würde den plan a dennoch
vorziehen diese mehrwertsteuer gar nicht
erst zu erheben bei den ärmeren
haushalten haben wir zudem ja bereits
auch andere instrumente er in
vorbereitung will das mal nur in
erinnerung rufen dass menschen in
grundsicherung also hartz 4 gar keine
gasrechnung sei aber nur für den fall
dass der arzt wenn die mehrwertsteuer
kommt was machen sie denn damit können
sie die umverteilen wie gesagt da müssen
wir miteinander beraten gerade die
ärmeren haushalte sollen ja profitieren
vom neuen wohngeld und auch von etwa der
übernahme der kosten der unterkunft
nehmen sie für heute einfach am tag
bevor die umlage kommt den politischen
willen der bundesregierung dass wir
nicht von der mehrwertsteuer profitieren
wollen
sie sich daraus dass sie noch davon
ausgehen dass dies verhindern könnten
ich bemühe mich nach kräften ich bin ein
europäisches recht gebunden und ich habe
mit brüssel kontakt aufgenommen und das
ist das was wir zur stunde tun kann im
moment ist es ja so dass diese gas
umlage die verbraucher von gasen nur die
verbraucher von das betrifft ja eh schon
durch einen hohen preis betroffenen sind
finden sie das eigentlich gerecht ist
ein solidarischer akt diejenigen
gaskunden und und maciel diejenigen
gaskunden die jetzt betroffen sind von
einer ersatzbeschaffung russisches gas
feld aus und es muss zu höheren preisen
nachgekauft werden die werden ein stück
entlastet damit da nicht so stark
durchschlägt und auf der anderen seite
diejenigen bei denen der preis weil sie
sich aus anderen quellen gas besorgt
haben bei den unternehmen da wird der
preis über die umlage höher was ist ein
solidarischer ausgleich innerhalb des
systems und ich glaube dass zusammen mit
den entlastungs maßnahmen die wir in
diesem jahr auf den weg gebracht haben
die teilweise ja auch noch kommen und
mit den maßnahmen die wir im kommenden
jahr ja noch vorbereiten dass wir da
insgesamt in unserem land für fairness
sorgen und insbesondere soziale härten
verhindern selten waren gewinne ja so
unverdient wenn man das so sagen kann
wie im moment bei den energiekonzernen
zum teil sind die gewinne ja
verfünffacht ohne eigenes zutun
es gibt die aussage dass die eu eine
über gewinn steuer zulässt auch der
wissenschaftliche dienst des bundestages
sagt das ginge bei uns sind sie bereit
über ihren schatten zu springen wie es
die grünen chefin vorschlägt das habe
nichts mit meinem schatten zu tun ich
mache mich stark dafür dass wir eine
globale mindestbesteuerung bekommen
damit auch die großen konzerne überall
ihren fairen beitrag zur finanzierung
des gemeinwesens leisten bei der über
gewinn steuer steckt allerdings der
teufel im detail es ist auch mein gefühl
dass man dort etwas macht aber bei
genauerer überlegung spricht vieles
nahezu alles dagegen ein
wissenschaftlicher beirat im ministerium
der es unabhängig warnt dringend davor
warum über gewinne fallen an zum
beispiel bei impfstoffherstellern also
sehr hohe renditen sage ich besser bei
ihm stoff hersteller der aber auch ein
hohes risiko haben sie fallen dort an wo
es knappe güter gibt und gegenwärtig zb
ist strom auch ein knappes gut deshalb
sind der hohe gewinne wir würden unser
steuersystem der willkür ausliefern und
besser passt zum beispiel das
französische parlament gerade aktiv
gegen eine über gewinn steuer
entschieden aber die italiener haben
dafür entschieden mit leichten problemen
aber die briten sind ja nun auch nicht
als antikapitalistische haupt bekannt
und die haben 25 auf die
mineralölkonzerne gelegt das ist naja in
deutschland haben wir keinen
mineralölkonzerne wir haben auch
energiekonzerne rwe hat den gewinn
verdoppelt rwe hat hohe gewinne
allerdings angekündigt dass sie deshalb
bei der gasanlage die verluste alleine
tragen werden wie gesagt ist eine
abwägungsfrage wir kommen dann erstmals
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik zu
einem steuerrecht wo nicht klar
kalkuliert ist ich habe einen gewinn und
die wird er beschwört zu werden sie
nicht mehr sondern ein stück willkür
alle die sich damit in meinem
ministerium beschäftigen warnen davor
und deshalb sage ich in deutschland sind
gewinne bereits sehr hoch besteuert wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass die knappheiten
überwunden werden zb das gas günstiger
wird sind damit sehr weit weg von der
meinung der menschen die umfragen zeigen
88 prozent der spd anhänger 84 prozent
der grünen-anhänger und auch eine
mehrheit in ihrer eigenen anhänger
möchte diese über gewinnsteuern das
zählt aber nicht ausreichend ich bin
meinem amtseid
unterworfen ich muss auch das tun wovon
ich überzeugt bin und was bei einer
klaren sachlichen erörterung rauskommt
und das bedeutet ja das amt des
finanzministers ist nicht in jeder phase
bequem darüber war ich mir aber auch im
klaren oft muss man an die grenzen
staatlicher finanzierbarkeit erinnern
oft genug muss man für fairness und
ausgleich im steuersystem sorgen und
kann nicht einfach überall belasten und
oft müssen auch regeln der der
nachvollziehbarkeit des steuersystems
verteidigt werden wo im konkreten moment
die öffentliche stimmungslage und das
gefühl in eine andere richtung geht und
das ist unbequem aber ich bin dazu
bereit der bundeskanzler hat ja gerade
jetzt ein drittes entlastungs paket
angekündigt steht in gewisser weise die
schuldenbremse für die sie ja sind
ich kann das als sie sind rund zwei
drittel der bundesbürger für ein
erneutes aussetzung jürgen trittin von
den grünen meint die schuldenbremse wird
weihnachten nicht überstehen sehen sie
die wette ein ja in diesem jahr habe ich
ja noch einmal von der ausnahme der
schuldenbremse gebrauch gebracht ich bin
da nicht ideologisch festgelegt das
entlastungspaket gut 30 milliarden euro
dass wir nach dem ukraine krieg
beschlossen haben das habe ich ja
möglich gemacht
wohngeldempfänger haben eine
einmalzahlung an heizkostenzuschüsse
erhalten einmalzahlung für
hartz-iv-empfänger 300 euro energiepreis
pauschale die kommt rückwirkende
steuersenkung beim krone 400 nach vorne
schauen die schuldenbremse ist ein gebot
unserer verfassung ich wundere mich über
die
einschätzung unserer verfassungsordnung
bei anderen kann nicht einfach nach
belieben eine ausnahme von der
schuldenbremse macht das heißt wenn die
lage bleibt dann ist für sie die
schuldenbremse gesetzt weil wir es nicht
mit einer neuen situation zu tun haben
richtig die schuldenbremse wird
ausgesetzt bei einem nicht
beeinflussbaren nicht vorhersehbaren
schock von außen nun leben wir aber in
der realität des ukraine kriegs mit
seinen wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
schon länger er kann es gibt auch noch
ein zweites argument ökonomisches
argument wir haben gerade inflation und
inflation bedeutet dass der staat das
seine tun muss um die ursachen der
inflation zu bekämpfen und das geht
dadurch indem er seine ausgaben seiner
verschuldung reduziert weiß kurzfristig
verlangt das von mir als finanzminister
fiel ab viele forderungen wir haben hier
unser gespräch begonnen mit dem neuen
euro ticket 14 milliarden euro viele
forderungen muss sich einordnen aber
mein ziel ist die ursachen der inflation
zu bekämpfen und eine ursache der
inflation ist auch die ausgabenpolitik
des staates wir haben ja gesehen dass
die ausgaben zum teil auch von der
inflation von den höheren zinsen
getrieben sind sie werden im nächsten
jahr statt vier milliarden
möglicherweise 30 milliarden für die
zinslast tragen wo kommt das geld her
das müssen wir im haushalt
erwirtschaften sie haben völlig recht
die steigenden zinslasten begrenzen
unseren spielraum in der vergangenheit
hat sie der staat verschuldet und hat
gerade zu gewinnen damit gemacht jetzt
zahlen wir sehr schnell sehr viel und
das ein weiterer grund warum wir mit der
verschuldung nicht so weitermachen
können wie bisher
sie ist nämlich nicht mehr kostenfrei
die schulden die wir jetzt aufnehmen
müssen in kürze bereits zurückgezahlt
aber woher kommt es gilt das kommt aus
dem staatshaushalt dadurch dass wir
sorgsam wirtschaften und nicht alles was
wünschenswert ist kann finanziert werden
denn wenn wir das mit schulden machen
dann werden wir binnen weniger jahre
steuern erhöhen müssen nur um die
schulden der vergangenheit zu bezahlen
wir würden unsere wirtschaft
strangulieren bevor wir zur fdp kommen
antwort sie im verhältnis zu porsche
nicht zu dem urteil einer garage sondern
zum konzern der porsche chef oliver
blume hat ja geschrieben wir uns ja vor
liegt in einer internen sitzung hat er
wörtlich gesagt wir haben sehr großen
anteil des e fuels in den
koalitionsvertrag geflossen sind er hat
sich im nachgegangen dafür entschuldigt
hat gesagt das sei überspitzt aber
überspitzt lässt ja viel raum auch für
interpretationen überrascht hat mich
eine sms von ihnen an den porsche-chef
schreiben sie ich kann da durchaus
argumentative unterstützung
gebrauchen da ging es im juni wir
erinnern uns im koalitionsstreit um die
verbrennungsmotoren und if you're der
bundesfinanzminister fordert per sms von
porsche-chef flankierende argumentation
unterstützung ist das normale nähe jetzt
haben sie aber sehr lange gesprochen mit
sehr vielen dingen die sie festgestellt
haben weshalb ich jetzt nicht kurz
antworten kann herr kohl zunächst einmal
es gab keinen kontakt mit porsche seit
meiner amtsübernahme bis die
bundesregierung ihre entscheidungen auch
zum verbrenner verbot getroffen hat gab
es keinerlei kontakte
koalitionsverhandlung hatte ich ein
einziges telefonat mit dem porsche chef
er hat übrigens auch mit den grünen
gesprochen ich habe meinerseits auch mit
unternehmen gesprochen die sich
einseitig auf die elektromobilität
festgelegen hatten und dass mir nicht
beeindruckt denn meiner auffassung für
technologieoffenheit die besteht seit
langem im übrigen betrachte ich ist auch
als teil meiner verantwortung dass ich
mit den branchensprecher wo millionen
menschen ihren arbeitsplatz haben wo
kämen wir denn da hin
dass die politik auch die
bundesregierung keinen kontakt mit der
wirtschaft pflegt nicht betrachtet das
jedenfalls als meine verantwortung und
konkret zu dem punkt ja nachdem die
entscheidung getroffen worden ist
das ist vor dieser entscheidung einen
kontakt gegeben hat habe ich herrn blume
gefragt angesichts der äußerungen der
grünen die die einigung der
bundesregierung wieder infrage gestellt
haben ob er seine fachlichen argumente
nicht auch einmal öffentlich vortragen
der kontaktlinsen wollen habe ich
einfluss auf ihn genommen für eine
position die für unser gemeinwohl
insgesamt von großem vorteil ist nämlich
die technologieoffenheit aber dieser
gesuchte kontakt ist ja durchaus eng
begrenzt offensichtlich deutsche
umwelthilfe sagte uns sie habe bisher
drei mal vergeblich versucht einen
termin bei ihnen zu bekommen man habe
auch keine handynummer von ihnen
greenpeace sagt das ähnlich auch der
deutsche naturschutzring also der
kontakt ist nicht so ganz ausgewogen ich
spreche mit allen und gerne aber gerade
bei der deutschen umwelthilfe sehe ich
keine position für technologieoffenheit
sondern eine sehr einseitige
positionierung
unserer politbarometer hat vorgestern
gezeigt wie unterschiedlich die ampel
parteien von der koalition profitieren
die grünen sind mit 26 prozent die
stärkste der drei parteien in der
stimmung sogar über 30 prozent die
liberalen kommen auf eher magere 7
prozent und auf sie persönlich sind
beliebtheits trophäen nicht so ganz nah
gerückt das gerne hübscher die lage
einmal in 60 sekunden zusammengefasst
ich schwöre es er hat es so sehr gewollt
bundesfinanzminister doch als er es
endlich ist verhageln im krise und krieg
das amt christian lindner kann zentrale
fdp versprechen nicht einhalten muss 100
milliarden neuer schulden für die
bundeswehr aufnehmen in der korona
politik muss er zuletzt karl lauterbach
nachgeben für neue masken pflicht statt
eigenverantwortung
egal was er tut lindner wird kritisiert
weil er mitten in der krise opulent
heiratet auf sylt weil er kommunikativ
passt wenn er von gratis mentalität
spricht die liberalen verlieren eine
landtagswahl nach der anderen stürzen ab
im bundestrend auf 7 prozent
die one-man-show lindner sie zieht
aktuell nicht mehr der minister selbst
deutlich unbeliebter als seine grünen
kabinettskollegen hadek der ewige
konkurrent du hast das alles vorher
gewusst
du hast das alles vorher gewusst sagen
sie zu sich selbst das ist vielleicht
nicht ganz korrekt mit dem krieg in der
ukraine aber schauen wir mal auf die
ampel alle parteien in der ampel müssen
tabus brechen aber es leiden vor allem
die liberalen warum ist das so
ich habe vorher bevor wir diese
regierung eingegangen sind ja gesagt
dass die ampel für die fdp eine große
herausforderung ist die wahlprogramme
sind sehr unterschiedlich wer regieren
als partei der mitte mit zwei linken
parteien auch unser gespräch hat ja
gezeigt immer wieder forderungen von spd
und grünen den koalitionsvertrag neu zu
verhandeln und die linie der politik
weiter nach links zu verschieben das ist
für die fdp und unsere unterstützerinnen
und unterstützer eine große
herausforderung auch in der frage und
insbesondere der korona politik stehen
wir ja für einen kurs der
selbstverantwortung möglichst viel
gesellschaftliches leben möglichst viel
freiheit haben der masken pflicht
zugestimmt gerade und dennoch sehen wir
auf der anderen seite dass es bestimmte
schutzmaßnahmen gibt und dass die fdp
nicht alleine auf der welt ist und
deshalb haben wir sicherlich einige
wählerinnen und wähler der
bundestagswahl die momentan mit einem
kritischen auge auf uns schauen aber wir
tun das was in unserer macht steht wir
tun unser bestes wir geben auch keine
überzeugungen auf anders als im beitrag
gesagt habe ich zentrale wahlversprechen
eben bislang nicht brechen müssen es
gibt keine steuererhöhungen übrigens
auch gedreht und nach höchsten
schuldenlast dieser republik aber auch
nach einer automatischen und die
schuldenbremse verteidige ich aber da wo
es notwendig ist wie nachdem ukraine
krieg da gebe ich auch von
schuldenbremse ab weil es notwendig ist
ja und ich kann wie gesagt nur das tun
wovon ich überzeugt bin was mir das
nachdenken auch empfiehlt und da muss
man in kauf nehmen das ist auch einmal
auf und ab so liebten sie haben gerade
gesagt sie werden immer wieder mit
forderungen konfrontiert auch den wärter
robert habeck fordert jetzt änderungen
an ihrem inflations entlastungs plan er
sagt dann muss das zugunsten kleinerer
einkommen verhindern der läuft ja ein
weiteres mal im grunde so ein
gutgläubiger
spiel ab das heißt die anderen fordern
und sie müssen sich dagegen sperren ist
das eigentlich ein vergiftetes amt
geworden dieses finanzministerium nein
das war mir vorher klar erholen und
genau deshalb habe ich sie angestrebt
wie ich eben sagte nicht weil es bequem
ist sondern weil nur hier die
möglichkeit besteht unsere republik auf
der mitte zu halten
spd und grüne haben einen
bundestagswahlkampf damit bestritten
steuererhöhungen zu fordern dennoch
überrascht mich wie mein
inflationsausgleichs gesetz sehr entlang
parteipolitischer linien diskutiert wird
cdu csu dafür spd und grüne dagegen
worum geht's wir haben auf der einen
seite mit wohngeld mit dem neuen
bürgergeld sehr viel was wir tun für
bedürftige menschen haben doch wohngeld
soll ausgedehnt werden dass zum beispiel
auch rentnerinnen und rentner stärker
profitieren die vielleicht in ihrem
kleinen haus sind und sorge vor der
gasrechnung hatte passiert das wäre
schon das haben sie schon erläutert also
sagen dass ich hab' ich möchte einmal
auf meine position erklären wenn sie
mich immer nur fragen warum ich nein
sagen muss ich sagen nämlich gerne auch
ja wir haben auf der einen seite die
bedürftigen wir mobilisieren viel geld
der steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahlern
auf der anderen seite haben wir die
mitte der gesellschaft das mittlere
einkommen in deutschland sind 43.000
euro und die leute die 30 40 50 tausend
euro verdienen das sind nicht die
topverdiener das sind leute die hier an
der technik sind das sind die
polizeibeamten das sind die ingenieurin
und die würden im nächsten jahren den
nichtstun belastet ich schlage nichts
anderes vor als einen steuerlichen
schutz vor inflation was die leute nicht
wenn sie ihre gasrechnungen bezahlen
auch noch mehr steuerlich überweisen
müssen sie haben vor einem jahr im
parteivorstand gesagt
eine ampel koalition gefährde die
existenz der fdp hatten sie damals
unrecht das ist ein zitat das nicht von
mir im o-ton aufgeschrieben wurde
sondern eine kolportage aus der sitzung
und deshalb kann ich damals wie heute
nur folgendes sagen die fdp ist diese
ampel aus staatspolitischer
verantwortung eingegangen weil cdu und
csu nicht regierungs bereit war wir sind
sie eingegangen weil wir mussten aber
wir sind in der ampel weil wir gutes
bewirken ich danke ihnen für das
gespräch ich danke ihnen auch das war
unser sommerinterview mit dem fdp
vorsitzenden christian lindner kommenden
sonntag sehen sie hier um diese
sendezeit sport die european
championship und am sonntag danach
trifft meine kollegin sharon terlep
energy den csu vorsitzenden markus söder
ihnen noch einen schönen abend und eine
gute woche
[Musik]